[Music]
two years ago businesses were forced to
close as covid became a reality in las
vegas some businesses managed to reopen
but some made the tough decision to
remain closed joe mohler is live on the
strip with how business owners navigated
the changes joe
two years ago businesses were forced to
close around the valley and business
owners had to figure out if they were
going to reopen or not now take a live
look here at three o'clock here on this
thursday the strip is now back open and
it resembles a lot of normalcy here but
not all businesses around the valley
were able to open their doors again
we
were forced to close like all fitness
studios were this henderson dog grooming
location was once a fitness studio
called sweat inspire live i owned a
fitness studio and owned it for three
years andrea hui said it was her dream i
had to make the really tough decision
not to go back to that and really not to
reopen it the pandemic forced her to
make a change this is my home office she
took her fitness knowledge and now
coaches people remote now i'm doing more
coaching one-on-one coaching with women
usually driven successful career women
and coaching them one-on-one
and that's what i do here and where i
create content she was one of many
during the pandemic who had to make a
change it was incredibly challenging it
still had a
massive impact a negative impact on us
courtney olsen had an e-commerce
clothing business called girl she
decided to open a retail shop there was
also a meeting space here on main street
at this store we spent roughly thirty
thousand dollars renovating this space
and five days before we were supposed to
have our grand opening system shut down
the city she never reopened she decided
to take all of her sales back online and
has been operating that way ever since
it's more or less just learning
to go with the flow as opposed to
thinking that you have a clear path to
what's going to happen
the closures hit nevada harder than most
states according to a report by yelp las
vegas ranked third among the cities with
the highest closures as temporary
closures and permanent closures the
industry that was hit the hardest during
the pandemic was the restaurant industry
reporting live on the strip joe muller
live local now